tom took him out just very uh quickly
from the foreign affairs point of view
do you understand uh gordon brown's
anger on the vaccination question and do
you agree with him that this is a
responsibility that should be in the
lapse of g7 leaders of course i
understand it and and most importantly i
think it's fundamentally in britain's
interest
to uh make sure vaccinations are rolled
out as quickly as possible around the
world for the very simple reason that we
know about all these variants coming up
around the corner you know we've had a
kent variant in indian variant and no
doubt there'll be many other variants uh
you know on their way and the faster we
vaccinate the fewer develop variants and
the less likely there is of subsequent
cross infection in the uk so this is
simply self-interest and that's why i
think we should do it
uh more important to get vaccines out to
uh developing countries than to
vaccinate children
well i don't know that's i'm afraid i'm
going to have to ask scientists on that
one um and it's not my area of expertise
so i'm i'm talking to people about it at
the moment actually funnily enough
all right well let's turn to afghanistan
um
you were plainly really deeply affected
by
what happened and the fact that
many of the people that you worked with
in your four years i think in
afghanistan
were left behind
how many people do you think remain
uh who need to get out the
vaccine's minister talked about low
hundreds
well i don't know again um but i've
certainly had contact with um the best
part of
best part of a hundred and i don't
suppose for a moment that i'm in i've
had contact with the majority so um you
know it's very hard to say and and for
everyone i've been in contact with
there's a family attached so low
hundreds strikes me as a an optimistic
uh optimistically low number
can you say anything about the efforts
in which uh you've been involved dude i
i read that you said you basically
hadn't slept
for weeks because of this but you've
been involved in efforts to
bring people out
well there's a collection of us who've
been uh working in different ways to try
and get uh folk out and we've had uh in
earlier days we had more success we've
had mixed success recently but i mean
it's it's it's really a series of uh
people us british connecting individuals
we know to
uh safe houses we know and and and
moving people around um
it's extremely uh fraught and it's
getting harder as the taliban and the
various different groups that are
affiliated with it um get better get
more in place get more structured so you
know we're seeing for example that the
biometric information that's been left
behind is increasingly being used at
checkpoints and that has seen certain at
least
one individual we know um captured and
sadly disappeared and i'm told
by others of several others
there's a fundamental question about
the way that our government has to
behave and that is what does it think
about the taliban do you
believe the taliban when they say this
is a new model they're going to be
different this time for example on the
quality of women and
and even if
they are
different in kabul and kandahar can they
enforce that change across the country
well trevor this is the fundamental
question who is the taliban i mean i
know who mula barada is and i know that
he negotiated in doha and spent two
years giving the us the run around
conceding nothing and accepting
everything
i know who muller omar's son
yakub is and i know that he has very
limited support in the quest of surah
but is used as a figurehead i also know
who sirajadin haqqani is who
allied with al-qaeda for many years
introduced suicide bombing to
afghanistan
and now controls kabul and i know who
many of the drugs dealers and informal
networks in the south are after all
those are the people we've faced in
helmand for so many years
but the idea that this is a single unit
and by negotiating uh with one group in
doha you achieve result in kabul i'm i'm
afraid it's not really true i mean this
is this is a very very divided clan
based
mob based
organization think of it more like the
mafia than a government
and you'll have a better idea as to how
it works
is there therefore any point in talking
to the taliban what would you recommend
should we be talking to the taliban and
if so which bit of it you you've
identified at least three streams and um
we know that there are many more as well
as the local warlords
well the uk has always had a policy of
uh
you know reaching out in different ways
to different groups i have to say i
think formal talks with the taliban are
somewhat bizarre idea given that it
doesn't have a formal structure you know
the fact that it still hasn't formed a
government what is it now uh two three
weeks after it uh it took kabul is
partly an indicator of the divisions
within the organization you know it is
it is fighting within itself as to what
it does so the idea that um these talks
are meaningful in a traditional sense
i'm afraid they're not and the idea that
the taliban has changed again i mean you
know this is it's got a much slicker pr
outfit i don't know who it's hired but
it's got
it's got a similar group to the people
who are doing isis pr in in northern
syria
but the reality that it's changed the
way it treats women or or murders uh
minorities like the hazardo minority
it's complete rubbish no that's still as
brutal and vicious as they were
one one very quick question if i may ask
you you interrogated the foreign
secretary this week and
rather embarrass him by quoting from a
document
um that he evidently did didn't
recognize as his own department's work
did you come away from that encounter
thinking that this was the best foreign
secretary that the government could
actually find in its ranks look i came
away from that thinking that there are a
lot of questions that the government
needs to sort out and the most important
one today is one that's been summarized
by general the lord richards in a piece
an article on conservative home website
which talks about having a unity of
process the one thing that really
concerned me about that hearing actually
there's a lot of backward looking stuff
in that hearing for very obvious reasons
because we need to understand what went
wrong the one thing that concerned me
going forward was the fact that we do
not have a single person a single
minister a single official responsible
for helping people who we owe duty of
care to in afghanistan and getting them
out and i'm delighted that vicky
atkinson is doing that in the uk that's
fantastic but we need somebody doing the
same thing in afghanistan
i'm trying to press you on this tom but
um you don't think he's up to it do you
well look trevor my job as the chair of
the foreign affairs committee is to
challenge whoever sits in that in that
seat so you're always going to see me
being somewhat more aggressive towards a
foreign secretary than towards any other
minister and that's literally the job
i've been asked to do by parliament so
you know i'm not going to get into this
conversation for the simple reason that
my job is to challenge rather like your
job is to challenge if somebody asked
you whether or not a minister was up to
it or not up to it you'd avoid the
question because your job is to
challenge whoever the minister is and so
you know that's what i've got to do